in other videos we have already talked
about the law of demand which tells us
and this is probably already somewhat
intuitive for you that if a certain good
is currently at a higher price that the
quantity demanded will be quite low and
then as the price were to decrease the
quantity demanded would increase so if
we were to graph demand and so this
right over here is our demand curve
where price is on our vertical axis and
quantity is on our horizontal axis which
is the standard convention and for most
economists you would have a downward
sloping demand curve what we're going to
do in this video is dig a little bit
deeper into why
we have that downward sloping demand
curve and i know what some of y'all are
saying well it kind of makes common
sense if the price goes down i would
want more of that and so so would
everyone else but let's dig into why you
would want more of something as the
price goes down
so one category of reasons why you might
want more of it as the price goes down
economists will call the substitution
effect
substitution
and this is the idea that if we're
looking at the price versus quantity say
of candy and let's say at first the
price is right over here at
four dollars and at four dollars the
quantity demanded in the market would be
let's say that is 100
units of the candy maybe it's a hundred
pounds of the candy
that if the price were to then go to two
dollars for some reason
so let's say the price is at two dollars
well then a lot of folks could say gee
that candy is looking a lot better
relative to other things that i might
buy with my money so for example people
might be picking between candy and fruit
and maybe at first they were both four
dollars a pound but now all of a sudden
if the candy is two dollars a pound or
two dollars per unit well then it's
looking a lot better relative to the
fruit so some of that quantity of fruit
people would have bought they'll say hey
now candy is a better deal i'm going to
substitute the fruit with candy and so
that's why you have a higher quantity of
candy demanded this might maybe be now
250 units
another major category why you would
expect this downward sloping demand
curve for normal goods and we'll talk
about things like inferior goods in
future videos is the income effect
income effect and in some ways this
might be the most intuitive well if the
price went from four dollars to two
dollars well the cost of those hundred
units would now be half as much it would
go from four hundred dollars to two
hundred dollars and so the market would
have an extra two hundred dollars to
use to buy things with and some of that
extra two hundred dollars they'll buy
more candy with it and they might also
buy other things with that
now the last dimension that economists
will often talk about for why the law of
demand is downward sloping like this and
we talk about this in other videos is
this idea of decreasing
decreasing
marginal utility
and that's that idea that that first if
if you're just that first amount of
candy there's going to be people in the
market who take a lot of value from it
they are just addicted to candy they
their their bodies are dependent on that
candy but as as soon as those folks are
satiated that next incremental amount
that next marginal amount the utility
might be a little bit lower and so as
you have more and more candy the
marginal utility goes down and so that's
another way of thinking about why we
have a downward sloping demand curve